Donald Trump jr. joins us live tonight's
Don thanks very much for coming on good
to you do you think you talked to a lot
of Republicans in Washington do you
think they understand the threat of woke
capitalism the alliance between the
activists left and big business that is
shutting down speech you know I think
they're starting to get it I think
they're starting to see it I mean that's
why I've tried to utilize my platform I
did a op-ed and we're Real Clear
Politics the other day because I see it
from so many real Americans juices guys
that are Second Amendment accounts
people that follow me like my politics
whatever it is and they're reaching out
to me when I made a big deal of this
saying WOW it you know it's happening to
me too but I have a platform to actually
do something about it there are guys
Kevin McCarthy has been pretty vocal
about it but the reality is that nothing
has changed I put up an Instagram post
two weeks ago about the smollett thing
because you know I had the gall to be a
little bit cynical about the entire
ridiculous situation that was laid out
and Instagram just deleted it
I sort of responded in my normal fashion
rather aggressively saying what's wrong
with this here's the problem yada yada
and I got inundated Tucker hundreds of
people sending me DMS Don you know my
account was shut down because I tried
liking one of your tweets or I tried
liking one of your father's Instagram
posts that was like him and his
grandchildren nothing even controversial
and time and time again I had to follow
you Don three times in the last week
because they keep unfollowing you
it's really sad and it's happening and
the excuse that well there's it's
spam-like behavior no spam-like behavior
is not making instagram unfollow people
who want to follow my content and other
conservatives so free speech doesn't
mean anything if people can't hear you
speak and this alliance between the
activists left and big corporations is
preventing people from being heard so it
is in effect an attack on free speech
the media benefits from our freedom of
speech they are the prime beneficiaries
of the First Amendment and yet they
don't even cover it and places like CNN
actually encourage companies to D
platform voices they don't think should
be heard why is the press standing by as
the First Amendment erodes well because
I you know again I think the major
of the press are now left-wing activists
they are on the side of that they are
not on the side that is being stymied
they are not on the side that is being
oppressed you know guys like me again I
can do this because I have a big
platform I have a big soapbox I can get
it out there but some of the little guys
they can't they don't have that ability
they just end up taking it and that's
what's happened you've never seen
someone on the left say huh it's weird
done all of a sudden I'm following Fox
News I was never following that like
many conservatives are complaining to me
and saying that all of a sudden they're
following these crazy left-wing accounts
that they never signed up for this is
happening it's a one-way systemic attack
on free speech and to me it reads like
it's a trial run for 2020 how are we
gonna do it I'm not saying that every
account is suppressed but you do it
enough you take off X percent of the top
you cut the message in half you you get
rid of some of the viral nature of what
my father frankly did very well in 2016
he played monkey in the middle with the
media and what they tried to do with
messaging he went right to his people he
went right to the people with his
message he didn't allow them to
manipulate it he went right over them I
think to me it reads as though they're
trying to figure out how to minimize
that ability again and let the media
which again what 93 94 % left-wing
activists at this point and let them
drive that narrative make sure that that
is the only thing that regular
hardworking Americans see and we got to
call it out we have to hit it
aggressively I mean I'm a little
surprised that the Republican Congress
has sat back well for the two years they
controlled the house they still control
the Senate and let this happen
is there a reason to have Mitch
McConnell as Senate Majority Leader like
what is the point of having a Republican
Senate if they can't stand up for free
speech especially when their own voters
are being targeted well listen I I hope
that this creates the platform for them
to sort of jump on board to get it like
I said if it's me and I'm seeing
literally hundreds of people those are
just the people who actually saw that
post and are willing to take the time to
reach out and send screen shots imagine
how many other people it's actually
happening to imagine how many don't even
realize that it's happening so you know
I
think the Republicans a lot of these
companies are getting a lot of benefits
from the government from from the
internet from all these things you know
it doesn't seem like it'd be fair to
have a one-sided platform and you saw it
I mean you covered it in the opening
segment what's going on with PayPal I
mean they're not even hiding it anymore
they're not even pretending anymore it's
just become the norm if Donald Trump has
shown conservatives one thing it's that
you don't just have to take the loss
when the other side wants you to you can
actually fight back you can fight back
and win I think we have to take you know
that message to heart I think we have to
start pushing back and I think we have
to start pushing back hard if we don't
we'll never get the chance again Tucker
and there's no Republicans elected
Republicans who will tell you it's just
the free market at work no it's not as
fascism and if you don't hundred percent
fascism that's not free market we know
it's not the free market it's ridiculous
so Michael Cohen sets testified before
the House Oversight Committee tomorrow
you haven't heard his testimony
obviously you've read stories about what
he may say or not what's your take on it
from what you know honestly my take is
you know I have my father I know he's in
Vietnam right now trying to negotiate
nuclear peace settlement with North
Korea after 60 years of failed attempts
trying to end the war trying to end
nuclear proliferation on the Korean
Peninsula
you have finally a president who's
willing to do it finally a guy who's
actually got a meeting with the other
side and for the Democrats to try to
counter program that kind of progress to
try to perhaps somehow distract him with
this nonsense by you know a convicted
felon who's been lying to those same
committees it just goes to show you how
much those Democrats really disdain
Trump but also America I mean who wants
to try to stymie that process who
doesn't want peace in the Korean
Peninsula who doesn't want to end
nuclear proliferation in a dictatorial
state I mean who doesn't want that
Tucker it's it's crazy but they show you
that they really hate Trump much more
than they like America because I get
nothing from counter-programming
those kind of peace talks with this
nonsense that's been
with a convicted felon other than they
just want Trump to fail even if it means
America fails and that's a really sad
state of affairs Tucker Donald Trump jr.
thanks very much for that thank you